aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler du
futur peut-être même du futur lointain
ça va faire encore une vidéo je vais me
sentir très loin de ma zone de confort
oui parce que pour un intellectuel et en
particulier pour un scientifique parler
du futur c'est dur comme le dit l'adage
il est difficile de faire des
prédictions
surtout concernant le futur à tel point
qu'il est devenu usuel de voir des
intellectuels affirmé que l'on ne sait
absolument rien du futur voir qu'il
n'est pas scientifique de se risquer à
faire de telles prédictions et ça a sans
doute à voir avec la méthode
scientifique telle qu'elle est souvent
exprimé à base de réfutabilité et de
reproductibilité ça notamment à cause
d'un certain fischer s'est gêné que je
prends plaisir à détester c'est pas bien
je peux pas m'en empêcher
quoi qu'il en soit pour un bail et bien
tout est à faire de prédictions il faut
toujours parié sur ce qu'on ne sait pas
tout en intégrant dans le pari l'étendue
de notre ignorance particulier moi qui
aspire à être un bail désir compétents
je me sens obligé d'envisager les futurs
probables tout en soulignant les
incertitudes sur ses futurs probables et
ce qui est fascinant quand on commence à
faire ça quand on aa de dire je ne sais
pas pour commencer à dire je me trompe
peut-être mais il me semble probable que
c'est qu'on en vient assez vite à la
conclusion que le 21e siècle va être
très particulier dans l'histoire de
l'humanité et qu'il est sans doute très
présomptueux de penser que l'humanité
survivra au 21e siècle avec probabilité
1 commençait bien sûr il ya le risque
d'extinction de l'humanité semblables à
celles subies par les dinosaures un coup
d'astéroïdes et de super volcan
certains estiment que ces événements une
probabilité de l'ordre de un sur un
million de survenir au 21e siècle et
leurs conséquences seraient désastreuses
les débris et les gaz issus d'une
collision ou d'une éruption risquerait
de recouvrir l'atmosphère terrestre ce
qui pourra conduire un emballement
climatique global en fait ça pourrait
même être pire
notamment si l'astéroïde est disons 10
fois plus gros que celui qui a causé
l'extinction des dinosaures
on pourrait assister à une extinction
quasi instantanée de l'espèce humaine
dans le même genre il pourrait même y
avoir des risques de sursauts gamma voir
des trucs encore plus farfelues pour
anticiper et éventuellement contrer ces
catastrophes potentielles
il semble alors indispensable d'utiliser
des systèmes de surveillance des
astéroïdes et des volcans qui soit
automatisé et il ya de bonnes chances
d'être utile pour extraire les
informations importantes des nombreuses
données qui serait ainsi collectées ceci
dit il semble que les probabilités de
ces événements au cours du 21e
qu'elle soit relativement négligeables
notamment en comparaison avec d'autres
catastrophes dont on m'a parlé en fait
la principale menace extraterrestre
c'est le soleil en particulier le soleil
bien loin d'être une boule uniforme et
plein d'activités électromagnétiques
potentiellement instables en fait de
temps en temps il ya même de bruce que
tempêtes solaires appelés éjection de
masse coronale qui peuvent conduire à
des effondrements des réseaux
électriques
et ça ça peut être catastrophique oui
parce que de nos jours la sécurité de
nombreux aspects des transports de la
santé de l'énergie ou de la finance est
géré par des algorithmes et si ces
algorithmes et sont interrompues on peut
assister une catastrophe
d'ailleurs même en temps normal le
soleil nous expose constamment à toutes
sortes de radiation et c'est une chance
inouïe que l'on est sur terre un
bouclier magnétique pour nous protéger
de ces radiations
ce bouclier est ce qu'on appelle aussi
le champ magnétique terrestre ou
magnétosphère et on ne comprend pas
forcément tout son fonctionnement et
s'il continuera gentiment a ainsi nous
protéger bref aujourd'hui anticiper et
comprendre ces élections de masse
coronale et les variations de la
magnétosphère est un champ de recherche
extrêmement difficile et vu les progrès
en ia pour prédire le comportement de
systèmes critiques notamment il ya aura
sans doute son mot à dire pour nous
protéger au mieux de ces radiations
extraterrestre bon ça c'est pour le côté
extra terrestre mais pas besoin d'aller
dans l'espace pour rencontrer des
risques de catastrophes planétaires sur
terre les risques sont déjà bien
nombreux en particulier de nombreux
intellectuels pensent que le plus grand
risque pour le 21e siècle et le risque
de pandémie
oui parce que même le virus de la grippe
qui mute chaque année pour un jour
devenir ceux qui tuent soudainement une
portion majeur de l'humanité voire toute
l'humanité à titre d'exemple lendemain
de la première guerre mondiale on estime
que la grippe espagnole a fait entre 50
et 100 millions de morts soit deux à
cinq fois plus que la guerre qui venait
d'avoir lieu
d'un point de vue comptable la vraie
tragédie du début du 20e siècle
ce n'est pas la guerre sauf que la
grippe espagnole c'était en 1918 et en
1918 les populations ne se déplaçait pas
rapidement d'un coin du globe à l'autre
ce qui limitait la capacité de contagion
du virus
de nos jours une infection semblables se
propagerait sans doute beaucoup plus
vite à travers la population mondiale et
causerait une pandémie globalisé reilly
n'est pas dit qu'on puisse à stopper
efficacement ce risque de pandémie et
même d'autant plus inquiétant que les
moyens techniques pour créer des virus
catastrophique
ont augmenté notamment suite aux progrès
en biotechnologie comme christophe kass
9 il y a donc à la fois un risque
accidentel suite à de mauvaises
manipulations en laboratoire et un
cercle risque de bioterrorisme
pour éviter de telles catastrophes de
pandémie il est indispensable de faire
avancer la recherche sur la
compréhension des remèdes potentiels et
la possibilité par exemple de créer
rapidement et en grand nombre des
vaccins ou autre mais il est aussi
indispensable d'avoir des outils de
surveillance en continu pour détecter
rapidement les risques de pandémie pour
toutes ces tâches il y a le potentiel
d'être d'une grande aide
en fait de façon générale il semble que
le plus grand risque de catastrophe
majeure au 21e siècle soit anthropique
c'est-à-dire causé directement ou
indirectement par l'one lequel plus
évident c'est bien sûr suivie d'une
guerre mondiale qui pourrait être causé
par le problème d'accès aux ressources
naturelles et par l'attention que
ceux-ci génèrent si souvent et cette
guerre pourrait alors devenir
catastrophique si elle finit par faire
intervenir les armes de destruction
massive comme l'armé nucléaire
en fait c'est pire que ça l'histoire de
l'armé nucléaire montre que l'on est
passé plusieurs fois à deux doigts de
son utilisation parfois pour des raisons
accidentelle par exemple le 5 octobre
1960 des radars ont pris un lever de
lune pour une attaque nucléaire
soviétique
ce qui a amené les forces américaines à
être en alerte maximale parce qu'en se
dirigeant soviétique khrouchtchev était
alors en visite à new york ce qui
décrédibilise est la menace d' attaque
soviétique mais le plus effrayant c'est
que ce genre de quasi crise est arrivée
à plusieurs reprises dans l'histoire
mais l'armé nucléaire
la seule arme capable d'exterminer
rapidement une grande population comme
on a déjà parlé dans l'épisode 26 puis
dans l'épisode 28 la combinaison de la
robotique est de l'île a le potentiel de
donner lieu à des armes autonome capable
de cibler un individu et de le tuer de
manière clinique
pire ce genre d'attaqué peut être
généralisé sans laisser la trace de la
personne qui aura prémédité ces meurtres
encore pire encore ce genre d' attaques
pourraient facilement se mettre à
l'échelle car dans l'avenir il devrait
être possible de concevoir des millions
voire des milliards de telles armes a
tué et ce qui est encore plus effrayant
avec de telles armes
c'est que notamment c'est un design
imprimable en 3d circulent sur internet
il pourrait être non seulement possible
mais aussi et surtout relativement
facile pour n'importe qui d'avoir accès
à de telles machines à tuer c'est comme
si au lieu d'avoir une poignée d'humains
capables d'appuyer sur un bouton rouge
qui lancent des attaques nucléaires
on avait alors des milliards d'humains
avec chacun son propre bouton rouge
dévastateur elle démocratisation de
cette technologie aurait alors de bonnes
chances de conduire à une catastrophe
majeure
pour éviter un tel risque de
démocratisation des armes de destruction
massive
il semble nécessaire de réguler
globalement leur partage et de veiller à
ce qu'aucune activité humaine ne puisse
conduire à l'accès à de telles armes
pour tous
il s'agit là d'un problème
redoutablement difficile et je ne sais
vraiment pas ce que l'on peut faire pour
diminuer significativement les risques
qu'on en arrive là en fait et c'est
assez étrange je l'admets il me semble
que la meilleure façon d'empêcher la
prolifération des armes en autonome
facile à produire c'est de déployer des
ja en charge de la surveillance contre
de telles armes de façon plus générale
quand on y réfléchit peut se dire qu'il
est incroyablement dangereux que
l'utilisation de telles armes soient
décidées par une poignée d'individus
humain oui parce que les humains peuvent
aisément se tromper sont souvent
inattentif ivre fatigué énervé et
manipuler on peut les faire chanter ou
les menacer directement
bref les humains n'ont aucune garantie
de fiabilité qu'il s'agisse de guerre ou
d'autres
ainsi pendant longtemps gérer des
données aussi importantes que les
données bancaires était un travail
humain quoi que ceux ci étaient souvent
aidés par des feuilles de papier et ceci
conduit à de nombreuses erreurs la
gestion des erreurs financières
représentent d'ailleurs toute une
industrie de milliards de dollars et
n'est pas infaillible non
réduire les risques d'erreurs et de
contention les banques ont alors cherché
à réduire l'impact des humains dans la
gestion des données en se tournant de
plus en plus vers des technologies de
l'information beaucoup plus sûrs
notamment vers la bloquer en fait en
cryptographie
on sait bien que la faille des systèmes
de sécurité et souvent l'humain
augmenter la sécurité de nos systèmes
semble donc requérir le remplacement des
humains par des technologies beaucoup
plus fiable est beaucoup plus difficile
à manipuler à de mauvaises fins ceci dit
concevoir cette technologie est un
problème extrêmement difficile et là
encore il est possible que les appuis cd
comme elle est déjà à mieux garantir la
confidentialité de nos données là je
veux sortir un truc un peu mais tu as
mais ce principe est même déjà appliqué
pour vérifier la fiabilité des
technologies en charge de la sécurité
et pour cause les failles des
technologies de l'information ont
conduit à de nombreuses catastrophes
dans le passé tout ça parce qu'à
l'instar des politiciens les
développeurs des programmes sont aux
aussi des humains et risque donc de
faire des erreurs qui coûtent cher mais
il n'ya pas que le risque d'erreurs
humaines ou algorithmique il ya aussi
tout simplement le fait que nos modes de
vie actuels ne sont pas viables au cours
du 21e siècle
on va assister à la raréfaction du
pétrole l'acidification des océans
l'eutrophisation des terres cultivables
la profusion des déchets plastiques
la perte de la biodiversité le
réchauffement climatique la pollution
urbaine et tant de catastrophes
environnementales qui sont déjà en voie
ces problèmes environnementaux risque
ensuite est d'engendrer des problèmes
économiques et sociaux comme les chocs
pétroliers la famine la malnutrition les
déplacements de population les problèmes
sanitaires les inégalités les émeutes et
les guerres civiles
et puis enfin et surtout il ya tous les
problèmes que je ne connais pas et que
personne ne voit encore venir c'est la
première fois de l'humanité que l'on vit
au 21ème siècle trou story avec toutes
les technologies les structures socio
économiques et les équilibres ou
déséquilibre écologique que l'on connaît
actuellement
on n'a pas encore de données sur l'état
à venir de ce 21e siècle et il est donc
très important de prendre la mesure de
notre ignorance
celle ci étant énorme quoi qu'il en soit
il me semble très probable que le xxième
siècle sera celui des plus grands
bouleversements de l'histoire de
l'humanité où vit une période
d'incertitude inédite et il va nous
falloir faire de notre mieux pour que ça
aille dans le bon sens car vu les
risques qu'on a déjà listé la survie de
l'humanité en 2100 ne semble absolument
pas garanti
la nymphe en a parlé de l'ia et de
l'environnement avec rodolphe de la
chaîne l'aurait d'ailleurs
n'avait par notamment de l'importance
d'utiliser des outils d'intelligence
artificielle dans le domaine de
l'agriculture pour savoir mieux comment
gérer les terres d agriculture qui
reprennent en fait en crabe le mans
compliquée et complexe qui dépend de
dernièrement deux paramètres il ya pas
mal aussi de vers album sur lequel on
peut jouer et john kerr fait remarquer
que du coup c'est un problème très
complexe que l'implémentation même de
l'ia dans ce genre d'industrie notamment
parce que a priori les acteurs sont pas
forcément eu des experts on y a du coup
il va falloir réussir à retrouver des
moyens de communiquer pour voir mieux
expliquant en quoi l'intelligence
artificielle peut aider les agriculteurs
oui parce que intégré liés à leur façon
de faire va complètement bouleverser
leur façon de faire qui sont déjà en
train d'évoluer un rythme assez
effrayant et surtout qui n'est pas
forcément toujours très plaisant voit
les choses évoluent très vite au niveau
de l'agriculture et c'est assez
compliqué et en effet ça c'est sans
doute une des raisons pour lesquelles ça
va être extrêmement difficile de mettre
en place des situations dont on a déjà
prouvé qu'elle marche mais j'ai envie de
dire que même avant cela c'est en
partant déjà de développer les
technologies qui dont on peut être
raisonnablement confiante qu'elles vont
vraiment améliorer grandement la
situation des agriculteurs
c'est une empreinte de transition et les
transitions peut être extrêmement
compliqué en tout cas elle va être un
petit peu violente est un peu compliqué
mais le problème c'est qu'il ya un petit
peu urgence à changer nos façons de
faire pour améliorer les rendements et
diminuer l'impact environnemental et je
pense que pour pouvoir motivé ce
changement de façon de faire c'est
extrêmement important de garder en tête
ce problème environnemental se dire que
juste la manière dont on fait
agriculture aujourd'hui et sous-optimale
et qu'il faut absolument l'améliorer
pour pouvoir réduire notre impact
environnemental
et si on se garde ça comme objectif en
tête c'est peut-être plus motivant pour
essayer de changer nos comportements
d'ailleurs cette remarque s'applique aux
agriculteurs mais en fait elle
s'applique à tout le monde
à chacun d'entre nous il faut changer
nos comportements et c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile il faut préparer
une transition et il y a un peu urgence
donc du coup on est forcément un peu
brusque et est malheureusement un des
problèmes qui est associé à cela c'est
que on comprend pas forcément tout ce
qui se passe autour de nous et du coup
on a tendance à considérer que ce que
nous dit
faire et un petit peu un petit peu
autoritaire et du coup cette transition
à faire est vraiment pas agréable à
faire c'est vraiment un des problèmes je
pense qu du coup c'est extrêmement
important de se rendre compte des enjeux
pour pouvoir accepter plus facilement ce
genre de transition
pour cela il faut plus de être plus
sensibilisés aux problèmes de
l'environnement et encore je recommande
élections ta vidéo de l'audio réveillera
et je pense qu'un des grands défis de la
vulgarisation de ces différents enjeux
c'est essayer d'avoir un aspect assez
attractif parce que les gens ne vont pas
écouté quelque chose qu'il trouve
extrêmement moralisateur extrêmement
chant et culpabilisateur et tout ça du
coup il me semble que c'est très
important d'avoir une relation avec les
gens les plus concernés financer des
gens qui ont pas mal d'impacts
environnementaux se dire en fait nous
tous et essayer de non pas à leur dire
ce qu'il doit faire
messier de les amener à se rendre compte
de l'importance des saisons jeu et pour
cela et c'est ce que je fais en tout cas
sur cette chaîne scène soit lorsque je
parle de maths notamment ce qui paraît
depuis un petit but en mais voilà qu on
essaie de parler de maths ce que
j'essaye de montrer avant tout c'est pas
tant les matelas
résultat mathématique en tant que tel
c'est d'abord essayer de susciter un
intérêt de montrer qu'il ya quelque
chose de fascinant à penser les
mathématiques et je pense que d'un point
de vue environnemental peut être qu il
manque pas mal d'efforts encore pour
montrer que l'environnement c'est
quelque chose d'assez les beaux côtés de
l'environnement dans la vidéo de dirty
belgy sur le mât cay qui est assez
intéressant de ce côté-là désir qu'il ya
vraiment un truc à protéger et qu'il ya
une certaine manière vraiment urgence
ainsi de protéger et grâce à de telles
vidéos peut-être qu'on peut amener les
gens adorent à s'intéresser au premier
roman talent ce qui va ensuite leur
permettre de s'instruire par rapport aux
problèmes environnementaux et ce qui va
ensuite à peut permettre de les motiver
à voir un changement de comportement je
pense que c'est un peu une stratégie un
petit peu alambiqué qui est qui est
assez compliqué à mettre en place et
c'est pas évident mais l' approche
beaucoup plus direct beaucoup plus
frontale est aussi très compliqué
d'ailleurs à aller dans la rue et ce que
les gens leur dire il faut faire gaffe à
l'environnement c'est pas vraiment ce
qu'ils veulent et je suis pas changé
d'avis faut avoir des méthodes un peu
plus subtil du coup les approches un peu
à la dirty biologie me semble très
intéressante de ce côté là et puis il ya
une autre solution qui est simplement de
travailler sur les initiatives qui sont
donnés directement aux différents
consommateurs et producteurs est
typiquement ça peut passer par davantage
de taxes sur les produits qui ont un
énorme impact environnemental
ça ça vraiment un avantage en plus
d'être une solution assez simple donc je
trouve ça assez pas mal après le
problème c'est que augmenter les taxes
c'est souvent un truc
effectivement les citoyens ne sont pas
en faveur de monter les textes souvent a
tendance à aimer se plaindre de devoir
payer des taxes carambole ajoute que
l'ia peut également contribuer à
d'autres industries damman en recherche
et développement pour pouvoir produire
notamment des nourritures alternatives à
l'agriculture classique qui pourrait
avoir un impact environnemental beaucoup
moindre carambole part notamment du
vertical farming qui est l'idée d'avoir
des de l'agriculture dans une usine et
c'est une approche qui englobe je trouve
assez séduisante donc pouvoir
comment ça va évoluer si on peut réduire
les coûts notamment parce que ça c'est
pas forcément encore très rentable mais
si on peut avoir ce genre d' usine à
fabriquer de la nourriture avec un
impact environnemental beaucoup moindre
que celui de la culture classique avec
si possible des rendements assez
comparable qui sont fabriqués
directement dans les villes du coup y'a
pas le problème l'impact environnemental
lié au transport et qu'il est capable de
nourrir et ville alors faudra aussi de
pouvoir du coup avec ce genre de
vertical termine par me produire toutes
sortes de nourriture donc les gens
consomment beaucoup pour l'instant j'ai
surtout l'impression que c'est
certaines légumineuses qui sont pas
forcément les plus les plus
nutritive en plus mon bref je pense
carrément de recherche à faire là dessus
et je suis assez ignorant donc je fais
pas pour avoir des bêtises à l'instant
et je pense qu'en tout cas l'idée
globale et elle est très intéressante
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
pas rentable et du coup il faut plus de
recherche plus de mise à échelle pour
réduire les coûts mais souvent dans ce
genre d'industrie les cours finissent
assez rapidement par chuter dès qu'ils
en plus de la demande ça peut faire des
économies d'échelle
si ces world usines se généraliser on
peut trouver des astuces pour réduire
les coûts financiers mais en termes
d'impacts environnementaux
il me semble que ce genre de solution
est vraiment vraiment pas mal et l'autre
solution technologique dont parle
carambole pour produire à manger avec un
moindre impact environnemental c'est la
viande est une vie trop c'est à dire la
viande de fabriquer directement à partir
pas d'un animal mais des cellules
souches notamment et ce genre de
pratique me semble avoir vraiment
énormément davantage à la fois si vous
êtes concernés par la cause animale et
la souffrance animale balagna pas
d'animal qui souffrent mais également
d'un point de vue environnemental ce
genre de procédé qui m'ont font encore
réussir à le mettre échelle aujourd'hui
il ya encore plein d'enjeux notamment
d'ingénierie qui sont liées à tout ça
faut essayer d'optimiser pas mal de
processus et sans doute qu'il ya peu
grandement aidé dans les deux cas
d'ailleurs également pour le parti
quelqu'un me à améliorer les processus
améliorer la rentabilité de ces
processus et à la fois ai-je entendu et
environnemental et d'un point de vue
économique et avec ce genre de
technologie on peut avoir vraiment un
impact global drastiques sur la manière
dont la nourriture est produite et du
coup sur l'impact environnemental de nos
sociétés humaines notamment par rapport
à servian de nuit trop je recommande
très vivement
un épisode de podcasts et iséroise qui
parle de ça qui parle-t-on de la
recherche dans ce domaine machine
learning apparaît au moins une fois de
mémoire dans le podcast et ce sont des
industries encore tout jeune qui cherche
encore à grossir et c'est assez
compliqué mais voilà je pense qu'il ya
vraiment de quoi si vous êtes intéressé
en plus par la biologie ou le machine
learning ce genre d'émotions et que vous
voulez faire un job qui est vraiment car
assez clairement bénéfique pour
l'humanité je pense que typiquement
travailler sur les technologies de
viande in vitro est une très bonne façon
de faire
du coup je vous encourage serait à
d'abord vous informer voir si ça vous
intéresse vraiment puis ici d'explorer
les opportunités qui pourraient y avoir
pour essayer de développer des
alternatives moins polluantes aux
méthodes de production de nourriture
classique
elle espère qu'ils allaient mais cet
épisode qui clôt enfin cette sous serre
et sur les impacts sociétaux des
intelligences artificielles à partir de
la prochaine vidéo
on va faire une autre mini série de
vidéos sur la morale des diamants
calquer les pros vers nous aujourd'hui
et on décide de se projeter sur vers
l'avenir et voir comment on peut
programmer morale désir qu'elle pourrait
être la morale des ja du futur et ainsi
de suite
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à
la ligue et à l'augmenter à le partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes de mercy au
départ peu lardons et j'espère que je
serai là
la prochaine fois mais aussi à une
probabilité de 1% que l'humanité
disparaissent d'ici la fin du siècle la
magnitude des conséquences est si grande
que l'importance et ce risque est
clairement à prendre en considération
comparé à disons le vol de votre voiture
qui a une probabilité bien plus grande
mais peu de conséquences si ce n'est de
vous énerver des matches
me dionne cinq niveaux d'expérience
entre